first this hour is gonna be Larry in
Tacoma Washington hey Larry how are you
any morning Dave how you doing better
than I deserve what's up in your world
well so right now I'm actually in the
beginning and I fell hard times and
staying in my car
but I'm reading your book and it's very
motivating and it's really common sense
so I'm about to start a job and I'm
motivated and I want to take care of
that in a future deficit and Wow what's
your new job I got a government job that
I bless so although I fell on hard times
I have a I'm anticipating this job so
I'll be working for the government for
DLT okay very cool am I gonna have all
kind of money forty five hundred a month
Wow when do you start
hopefully I start I do my drug test and
screening in two and a half weeks they
called me last week they looked over my
credentials and whatnot until what kind
of hit it in that direction excellent
excellent
good for you so did I hear you right you
said you're living in your car my car is
reading your book and very hopeful you
know it's a lot of common sense of
practical things but so naive and
ignorant in terms of finances and me
personally made a lot of bad choices but
as I read your book and get more in
depth of it it's uh it's very very
hopeful and I thank the Lord for that
good well praise God man it sounds like
you're getting it turned around I'm
proud of you very well done
there's always a light at the end the
tunnel that's not a train right right so
uh how old are you 31 okay you know and
you're single I take it well yeah
because of my bad decisions I am today
like you don't have to
but I'm just curious because I don't get
a lot of calls like this
what were your bad decisions that put
you in the car oh man first formal I'm
not trying to get religious on all the
callers but it's not doing God's will
you know just plain and simple in that
regard but I mean poor choices many a
poor choices with my finances with
credit card debt I had a auto loan and I
financed that God repo and while I'm
talking to you thing in this car that I
have not it's actually they could get
repo'd if I don't like this job sooner
than later so I'm kind of in a dilemma
mm-hmm and how much debt do you have now
well I have my in my budget yesterday I
bought a big of a bulletin board from
Dollar Tree which is only a dollar and
I'm in the 27,000 okay 27,000 how much
of that's the car I think about 11,000 I
got two student loans that accumulate to
about 6,000 and I got like that credit
card debt mm-hmm okay good good yeah
you're gonna blow through that real fast
making 4,500 your your not your life's
not gonna change just a little bit it's
gonna change freakin dramatically dude I
mean absolutely amazing so uh what's
your living plans for the next two and a
half weeks just the car and then start
work out of the car or you got something
else figured out you have anything in
the car for about two months now but one
day at a time so hopefully in the next
two weeks I'll be in the car but I'll
eat a little better you know okay that's
cool the shelter they're helping you in
the area yeah yeah I really charts also
also more so I go to the church I try
not to just go anywhere because there's
a lot of crazy people you know the world
we live in today absolutely I gotta
watch where I go absolutely so the bad
choices you made any of those involve
substance abuse yeah how long you been
dry
oh man about four four and a half months
way to go dude
well done well done time
well you're turning it you're turning it
you've identified the the steps you've
got to take to turn it around and you're
doing the right things and I'm proud of
you how can I help you well no I wasn't
wanting to say thank you because I came
across your Total Money Makeover book
from my sister-in-law and I'm in the
middle of it and everything makes sense
and I look at my credit cards and just
two days ago ago excuse me I cut it and
I look at all my finances I'm like man I
put myself in this predicament but
there's light at the end of the tunnel
if you made mention of so I'm very
motivated and inspired by your book and
I wanted to say thank you yeah well
thank you I'm motivating inspired by you
dude you're you're doing all the right
stuff after having done all the wrong
stuff so you can't ask ask any more of a
man than that and you squared your
shoulders and you face the demons down
you turn the corner I'm very very proud
of you I want you to go through our
class Financial Peace University and I
want to pay for it they'll be one taught
in a local church there that we can get
you plugged into I'll put you on holding
Kelly I'll pick up and do me a favor as
you're going through that class call me
back this fall and tell me tell some of
our listeners and me the story of how
this is continuing to turn around your
inspiring dude any thanks thank all you
folks over there as I contemplated I'll
call it what I said hey I'm starting
then I do I definitely wanted to call
you when everything that's better and
make progress yeah cool we want to hear
the follow-up on your life man you're
doing good stuff hold on Kelly I'll pick
up and we'll get you signed up for
Financial Peace University that's
something we can do to help you lift and
you stay plugged into your local church
here and they'll walk you straight into
that new job and straight into the new
life that's ahead of you very well done
sir very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]